OK, let me go to our caller from the 585 who's
calling today from 5 8 5.
Hi, David, this is Kyle from Rochester, New
York.
Hey, Kyle, what's going on?
Beautiful, pristine connection, by the way.
A question about the Corona virus.
Sure.
In New York, in New York, we're supposed to
be in RPK really like right about now.
Yeah, and it's supposed to last for the week.
So according to the projections, we're not
supposed to have any more than 10 deaths a
day after April 30th.
So this will with this, will our state be
able to reopen up or since most states didn't
implement any stay at home features, we'll
have to wait longer.
My guess is that Andrew Cuomo will probably
start.
Hello.
I love it, hear me?
Yeah.
There was just.
It's you're cutting down on noise in the background,
though.
That was weird.
Most likely New York is going to have to start
implementing some opening up.
So it'll be like older folks should probably
still stay home medium to older folks should
stay home if they have any kind of co-morbidities.
Younger people, people who have already recovered
are going to be able to start getting a lot
of elements of the economy going.
I think that the responsible way would be
to do it slowly to see and try to avoid a
very quick second wave, which likely is coming
in the fall anyway.
Yeah.
So would you.
You probably wouldn't see schools opening
up anytime soon.
I think I was away for the year.
You know, I would be surprised if any schools
that have canceled so far go back because
many of them are would only be going back
for a few weeks or a month at the most.
So I'm seeing more and more places, say, schools
done for now.
We're going to pick it back up in the fall.
OK.
And then I have one more question, if we have
time to.
OK, so with Bernie dropping out today, how
can we convince Red Rose Twitter to vote for
Biden?
What is Red Rose Twitter?
I don't even know what that means.
So it's a bunch of like people and you see
like the red roses and they all bear the water.
Oh, boy.
All right.
Your connections imploding.
So many of them go.
I'll try to figure out what Red Rose Twitter
is, but continued deep connection issues today.